[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors quoi de beau cet
été j'espère que vous passez des bonnes
vacances moi aussi j'espère pour les
miennes pour ces vacances on a prévu un
petit best of avec tous les meilleurs
moments de micro-trottoirs il y aura du
pack Opal pack il y aura du premier
avril et il y aura un peu de détente et
un peu de repos tout ce que je vous
souhaite pendant ce ces vacances bien
sûr et surtout de la détente et du repos
il y aura l'effet de foraine il y a des
extraterrestres et les pièces les
numismates pile ou face au pile ou face
il y aura de tout mais en bien c'est une
météo où on présente plus du tout la
météo et c'est plus long voilà je vais
danser un peu
[Musique]
qui vous êtes je suis Thomas fetcherche
présente la météo du weekend tous les
week-ends
est-ce que tu écoutes un peu de jazz
non pas trop pourquoi j'écoute plus de
rap est-ce que vous écoutez du jazz
et puis
incroyable
non c'est la journée internationale du
Jazz tu écoutes qui en rap
oui tu peux nous faire un petit un petit
coup là
c'est lequel je sais pas encore écouté
non ça c'était à l'époque de ma jeunesse
on y est
de l'investissement ok ah ouais pas mal
du tout
[Applaudissements]
je suis un peu plus long
avec nous Chantal
c'est très bien vous mais je comme une
escalope alors vous pouvez pas faire la
danse des escalopes
[Rires]
OK
et tu le trouves comment franchement tu
peux le dire il y a pas la caméra
ça c'est par contre désolé c'est vrai
il y a les épaules c'est l'Algérie
merci pour tous ces mouvements deuxième
leçon la semaine prochaine OK
je pars pas très loin je pars à Chartres
voilà c'est ça
voilà quoi
[Musique]
détente et puis
se balader
beaucoup de repos ouais parce que là où
j'habite franchement on peut pas se
reposer il faut du repos il faut du
repos on travaille dur on travaille dur
toute l'année il faut se reposer un peu
voilà donc là les vacances c'est détente
et repos détente et repos et puis
profiter quoi bon repos et bonne détente
ah oui surtout la détente
équivalents
bon repos madame détente
merci on a croisé une collègue qui
cherche des bouquins sur le repos et la
détente surtout sur le repos par contre
quand même la détente mais quand même le
repos
qui va changer le monde
qui a changé ma vie ok
on garde vous avez des vacances de prévu
monsieur oui allez vous avez une piscine
là-bas ok ça m'intéresse moins pourquoi
revenir avec vous ouais
ouais non mais c'est pour le repos le
repos de quoi la détente des qui de nous
deux moi plutôt
on va interview
c'est une veste
petit comment comme ça
qui s'occupe des prix peut-être non
[Rires]
je chauffe la piscine
comment via mon être
un peu plus large pour faire chauffer
avec mes parents
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un pile ou face parce qu'en
fait dimanche c'est la journée des
numismate
donc ça c'est ça c'est face ça c'est
pile ou face
[Rires]
c'est très bon merci beaucoup allez le
gars OK
bah bien joué
[Rires]
de la joie
vous êtes content pile ou face
monsieur dommage
vous avez perdu le droit de rejouer
on l'a fait pour de vrai
est-ce que ça vous dit de jouer un pile
ou face
j'ai des faces
[Rires]
j'ai gagné quoi vous allez gagner le
droit de rejouer c'est tout
mais non c'est pas mal c'est bien pile
bam c'est repudre encore
du coup il a
gagné quoi alors le droit de rejouer
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai perdu et
surtout ben le droit de rejoindre
[Musique]
ça c'est un tuyau je peux taper ça
donnera rien du tout on dit que les
claviers sont accouplés ok alors
pourquoi parce qu'en général l'organisme
il a que demain
merci chef
[Rires]
[Musique]
et le voisinage il se plaint pas ah non
parce que ça ne fait pas de bruit du
vent
je sais pas faire
[Musique]
celui-là
on peut jouer de la guitare
[Musique]
le facteur d'orgue
ça fait
toute à coup on entend un son unique il
dit c'est bon et on passe à la note
d'après
[Musique]
des pâtes par hasard
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez des techniques pour
cacher vos œufs vous oui
dedans
et où
il est bizarre à votre costume ah oui je
le prends bien
pour nous montrer un peu cette technique
de professionnels faut visiter ma
boutique c'est là où je l'ai cache alors
là par exemple visible pour les enfants
c'est il faut que ce soit visible mais
pas visible voilà ok par exemple dans le
trou là le petit trou là là
donc dimanche vous le mettez là
la boutique et vous mangez quand même du
chocolat le dimanche non d'accord et
joyeuses Pâques du coup
mais comment vous faites vous
réceptionner les cloches bah là il y en
a deux qui se présentent comme ça que je
viens de croiser dans la rue
non non mais c'était effectivement des
questions mais c'est des questions
primordiales
[Musique]
on cherche des œufs je sais pas s'il y
en a dans le dans l'établissement
des autres Pâques et alors c'est quoi
votre technique pour les cacher monsieur
la porte la porte ok là je cherche j'en
trouve
il faut peut-être que je me mette à
chercher mais donc là ça aussi c'est du
chocolat
ça aussi
[Musique]
ah oui oui déjà on bloque avec l'index
mais dans le pouce
OK
alors
elle a déjà le mauvais beaucoup plus
simple
mais j'ai pas le hop moi
ça se voit que ça va vraiment vite là
[Musique]
oh non j'ai fait une connerie je crois
et après je prends du coup celle-là là
j'ai arrêté de serrer j'ai arrêté de
tenir j'ai l'impression que l'histoire
du coup c'est une connerie et là maman
qui me manque ah non mais là ça
m'arrange pas du tout là et que je vais
mettre dans lequel dans ce cadre de ma
droite là
je l'avais presque je transpire Brigitte
là oh là là
mais je sens que je suis pas loin mais
je vois pas comment je passe d'un fil
d'un fil en fil je l'ai perdu j'ai tout
perdu là
bam j'ai l'impression que c'était moi
qui font plus que les mêmes quand même
là à la vache en fait j'ai compris je
crois le principe
pour aller plus vite je fais deux par
deux mois
ce weekend c'est le changement d'heure
on va dormir pareil
[Musique]
je me couche à 7h25 exactement je me
réveille donc là ce sera 6h25 non ça
sera 7h25 8h25
juste que ce soit plus ou moins une
heure c'est septembre
[Rires]
faire un truc là
on peut t'accompagner quand même là on a
reçu tous les fûts toutes les tireuses
waouh il y a encore un camion qui arrive
avec des fûts chaque fût fait 30 litres
responsable bar public ok stylé un vrai
contact faut le garder là vous êtes tous
bénévoles ok
de débile tu peux faire un truc de
débile je suis capable de faire ça
Baptiste t'as pas un truc débile à faire
la canisse bah parfait tu vas faire de
la canisse allez faisons de la canisse
est-ce que c'est la canisse pour l'enfer
le soir du festival je me déguisé en
dinosaure on peut voir ton costume ou
c'est je n'ai même pas encore vu
moi-même
on va essayer de trouver quelqu'un pour
un test Manu tu as envie de faire cobaye
les dinosaures sont revenus
c'est vrai fais un bruit c'est un bruit
[Musique]
vous voulez quelle couleur chef j'ai
plein de petits poissons
[Musique]
connaissez l'histoire des deux nanas qui
m'attendent à poil
bah moi non plus c'est dommage
d'histoire comment c'est bien
c'est moi qui l'ai découpé à la main bam
on a eu quelques clients avant il me
reste trois poissons
là c'est bien là voilà
[Musique]
bonjour à tous
allez alors quoi de beau ce weekend dans
les Yvelines c'est super compliqué
heureusement que j'ai deux vitesses
je sais pas comment ça
alors est-ce que vous faites gagner des
cadeaux on a quelques petits goodies à
distribuer en effet
merci est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour en gagner
est-ce que vous allez bien madame ça va
super bien
est-ce qu'on peut les observer s'il vous
plaît regardez moi j'ai déjà gagné un
gros stylo oh la vache avec mon équipe
bonjour l'équipe
bonjour là vous voyez à ce stylo là je
vous laisse il faut que vous tâtiez le
produit quand même je peux en voler un
ou deux ou trois c'est un cadeau oh
merci là par exemple je peux partir avec
là on dira rien prenez pas le sans
contact
c'est du vol Airbus
tu as déjà deux stylos
attends il y a un cadeau derrière le
cadeau et il y a un truc derrière là
c'est infini
le bénef oh là il y a du match bonjour
vous m'intéresse beaucoup les lunettes
aussi
du gel hydroalcoolique à l'intérieur non
[Musique]
ça c'est classe et il y en a déjà dedans
du gel
ok faut qu'on trouve du gel ça existe ça
ben je la prends en même temps que vous
[Musique]
ok j'ai pas envie c'est pas grave on se
lave les mains c'est pas grave c'est
tout en fait
merci
ouais j'ai les mains propres le rose ça
va très bien
[Musique]
et voilà
alors ce dimanche c'est la journée
internationale des ovnis vous y croyez
où non
n'est pas un alien
vous êtes un vrai faux alien
est-ce que vous y croyez vous
j'en ai une
certaine
objet volant dans l'identifier sans
doute mais ce que vous voulez faire dire
c'est que s'il serait la manifestation
d'une vie extraterrestre et là non je
pense que on est dans le fantasme salut
les gars est-ce que vous croyez aux
ovnis
extraterrestre bavard vous connaissez
Raël ce qui se passe c'est que sur la
planète vegan j'ai été programmée
intelligence a fait artificielle on est
bien en avance sur vous alors j'essaye
si vous voulez quand même un logiciel
qui permet de contextualiser ça que mon
intelligence artificielle intègre
bûcheron clown de chez Pinder ils vont
poser une question c'est un peu sa
glaire compliqué extrêmement intime
intrusif vous avez reconnu tout de suite
un extraterrestre voilà j'ai deux cœur
non mais c'est Monia qui déconne
[Musique]
c'est bientôt le printemps
j'ai quelques questions ça vous dérange
pas
c'est pour 78
salut les gars je peux jouer avec vous
100 % je craque le pantalon première
utilisation là c'est les informations
des Yvelines
j'étais parti j'étais parti
allez allez
ça vous dit quelque chose
ouais c'est ça
OK
reprise
et en fait je suis un peu stressé
n'hésite pas à partir de là
la journée mondiale du mot de passe
est-ce que vous avez des mots de passe
nous partager là des conseils de mot de
passe c'est-à-dire
de changer assez régulièrement
régulièrement tout à fait est-ce que
vous avez des techniques moi j'utilise
un seul mode passe depuis plus de 15 ans
et le prénom de ma mère et le prénom de
mon père en majuscule avec les dates de
leur naissance respective on peut avoir
le nom de votre père le nom
de passe il va falloir changer samedi
alors pour la journée mondiale du mot de
passe c'est ça c'est exactement ça
effectivement nous avons prévu
effectivement un rassemblement secret
dont le lieu sera
la nature du Dieu sera délivrée
sur les réseaux sociaux le plus
tardivement possible là je mets le flou
je vous en supplie
donc rassemblement de la secte du mot de
passe durant laquelle effectivement nous
sacrifierons des mots de passe comment
on rejoint si imaginons j'ai un bon mot
de passe à cramer
alors il faut absolument que ce soit le
vôtre que vous souhaitiez effectivement
délivrer ça c'est très important le
consentement c'est très important en
délivrant effectivement vos coordonnées
votre groupe Rhésus et votre pointure
gauche avec en recommandé mais sans
accuser de réception sur tout puisque
nous ne accusons absolument personne
ok en fait on m'a conseillé d'utiliser
des longs phrases sans espace mais avec
des points c'est pas du tout pas mal
j'ai déjà mes idées
et moi je bip au montage comment ah oui
vous pouvez le dire
est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
week-end c'est la journée olympique oui
des quoi des choses Olympiques
qui va se passer là avec des sports et
tout
est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
weekend c'est la journée olympique ma
foi noire bon pourquoi pas mais les Jeux
Olympiques on en reparle un peu beaucoup
trop on est d'accord
on peut vous
est-ce que vous saviez que ce weekend
c'est la journée olympique du tout et
ben plaisir de vous la prendre ok ça
marche pas tout à l'heure bonjour
monsieur
sachez que ce weekend c'est la journée
olympique
merci il y a que la cravate
vous avez une passion un peu sportive
non plus pour l'instant c'était la
course la course la course
de javel liste
est-ce que vous vous seriez vu en tant
que sportif par hasard
ez
le rendre j'en ai fait un bout de temps
ok c'est quoi le poste
technique
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous visez une médaille
déjà
est-ce que moi je vais courir pour le
podium
[Rires]
là si vous pouviez ce serait quel sport
là si je pouvais ouais la reine des prés
j'ai mal au coude
comme ça on fixe le gardien et on tourne
le poignet comme il faut donner un effet
ou ballon qui retourne dans le but allez
là là elle est dans la tout à fait
dedans allez il est où
[Musique]
elle est bonne la pêche pour elle elle
est bonne
et voilà bravo il y a des objectifs là
vous avez un objectif de points juste
pour le plaisir de toute façon
comment on gagne chez vous là
franchement c'est bien c'est drôle quand
les gens ils tombent et tu m'as mis la
tronçonneuse aussi ou pas
c'est juste une surprend les gens alors
que moi les gens ils voient
ils ont peur faudra lui dire au clown il
y a pas de souci je vais lui faire une
formation prends la noire pour la noire
regarde elle a gagné elle a gagné là-bas
regardez c'est normal
on a gagné
[Musique]
au centre
madame innocence une fois innocence
pour Monsieur parce qu'il n'y arrive pas
allez vas-y fort
un poisson
yes on a gagné un poisson moche oh merci
c'est très gentil merci
[Musique]
c'est la bonne c'est la bonne
réfléchis
encore
accélérateur ici
[Musique]
j'ai plus de bras mais c'est cool